foreign
this is Professor in dust science and
today we will discuss how to write two
by two matrices in terms of powerly
matrices in another one of our videos on
rigorous quantum mechanics the states
and operators of quantum mechanics are
described using a vector space that we
call the state space while many Quantum
problems require the use of infinite
dimensional State spaces simple
two-dimensional State spaces are also
very important they are required for the
description of any two-state Quantum
system and perhaps the most famous of
all is that of spin one-half particles
like the electron but there are actually
many more because two-state systems play
a key role in many areas of physics from
Quantum Computing all the way to
particle physics Associated phenomena
have also received a lot of attention
for example the case of rabi
oscillations quantum operators
associated with two states systems can
be written in terms of two by two
matrices in this video we're going to
introduce a very convenient way of
writing two by two matrices which is
going to greatly simplify our study of
two State systems specifically we're
going to demonstrate that any two by two
Matrix can be written in terms of the
identity Matrix and the three polling
matrices so let's go
let's start with the 2x2 identity Matrix
let's also write down the powdery
matrices starting with Sigma 1
then Sigma 2
and then Sigma 3.
in today's video we will use these four
matrices as a basis to represent General
two by two matrices and when we do that
the identity Matrix is typically called
the zeroth parody Matrix and we can
label it with a sigma zero
moving forward I will assume that you're
comfortable with the properties of the
pounding matrices and you can find all
the details in the video that is linked
below
right so consider a general complex two
by two Matrix a with Matrix elements a 1
1 a 1 2 a21 and a22
in the most General case these Matrix
elements will be complex numbers
today's video is really simple we're
going to show that we can write any two
by two Matrix a in a unique manner in
terms of the identity Matrix and the
Pauli matrices
and specifically we will show that we
can write a as a linear combination of
these four matrices
where the expansion coefficients D mu
are in general complex numbers
using the explicit form of the matrices
we get the a matrix
equal to d0 times the identity Matrix
plus D1 times the sigma 1 powerly Matrix
plus D2 times the sigma 2 powerly Matrix
plus D3 times the sigma 3 power Matrix
and we can combine these four terms into
one
first note that the only two terms
contributing to the diagonal elements
are the term proportional to the
identity Matrix and the term
proportional to the sigma 3 Matrix
they lead to these two diagonal terms
we also see that the off diagonal
contributions come from the sigma 1 and
the sigma 2 matrices
and we get these two off diagonal terms
comparing the original expression for a
on the left here with this final
expression on the right here
we can write down the conditions that
the expansion coefficients D must obey
for this expansion to work and these are
the conditions that the diagonal
elements must obey
while these are the conditions that the
off diagonal elements must obey
so what we need to do is to show that it
is indeed possible to write down any
complex two by two Matrix as the linear
combination of the identity and powerly
matrices as shown in here
to put it another way we need to show
that the identity Matrix together with
the three poly matrices former bases in
the space of complex two by two matrices
so how do we show that these four
matrices do indeed form a basis
we need to show two things
first we need to show that these four
matrices are linearly independent
second we need to show that we can write
any complex two by two Matrix as a
linear combination of these four
matrices
so let's start with the first condition
to show that a collection of elements of
a general Vector space such as our four
matrices are linearly independent we
need to consider their linear
combination
giving the zero element
these elements are linearly independent
if this equation can only be satisfied
by D mu equal to zero for all mu
conceptually these elements are linearly
independent if we cannot write any of
them in terms of the others
if you remember this result from your
linear algebra course great if not I've
included a link in the description to
the corresponding Wikipedia page so you
can convince yourself of this statement
in our case we have that the linear
combination of the identity and powerly
matrices can be explicitly written like
this
and the linearly independence condition
is such that this equals the zero Matrix
comparing the diagonal terms here and
here gives these two equations
from the second equation we conclude
that d0 equals D3 and then from the
first equation we can conclude that they
are both equal to zero
moving to the off diagonal terms here
and here gives these two equations
and adding these two equations gives 2d1
equals to zero which implies that D1 is
equal to zero
and subtracting the two equations gives
that minus 2i D2 equals to zero which
implies that D2 is equal to zero
so overall we see that the only linear
combination that gives the zero Matrix
is one for which all of d0 D1 D2 and D3
are zero which proves that the identity
Matrix and the three poly matrices are
linearly independent
we've now proved the first condition
here to demonstrate that these four
matrices form a basis for the space of
complex two by two matrices
so let's now consider the second
condition
we need it to show that any Matrix a can
be written as a linear combination of
the identity Matrix and the three Paoli
matrices as shown here
remember also that we can write this
down explicitly as the Matrix a having
to be equal to this combined Matrix in
terms of the expansion coefficients d
all we need to do now is to show that
for any possible values of the a matrix
elements we can find four expansion
coefficients d
comparing the diagonal terms here and
here gives these two equations
adding them together gives a11 plus a22
equal to 2D 0.
this implies that d0 is equal to one
half times a 1 1 plus 82
subtracting them gives this equation
which implies that D3 is equal to
one-half times a 1 1 minus a22
now moving to the off diagonal terms
here and here
gives these two equations
adding the two equations gives a12 plus
81 equal to 2d1
this result implies that D1 is equal to
one half times a one two plus a21
subtracting them gives this equation
this implies that D2 is equal to I over
2 times a 1 2 minus a 2 1.
and that's it
for any Matrix a we can write it as a
linear combination of the identity
Matrix and a powerly matrices by
choosing the expansion coefficients
using these four expressions for d0 here
D1 here D2 here and D3 here
in the most General case these D
expansion coefficients are complex
numbers
we've now also proved the second
condition here and therefore we can
conclude that these four matrices do
indeed form a basis for this space of
complex two by two matrices
and this result is extremely useful
because it turns out that the parody
matrices are a very convenient set of
matrices to work with in many Quantum
problems involving a two-dimensional
State space with perhaps the most famous
example being the description of the
spin angular momentum in spin one-half
particles like the electron
we can formulate any operator acting on
a two-dimensional State space as a
complex two by two Matrix and a very
important family of operators Within
These is those associated with physical
observables we know that these
observables are described by a very
specific class of operators namely by
hermitian operators
and remember that a hermitian operator a
is such that it is equal to its adjoint
we're now going to explore what this
implies for the Matrix formation in
terms of the identity Matrix and the
power matrices
let's write down the adjoint of the
Matrix a
and explicitly it's given by calculating
the transpose of a and then evaluating
its complex conjugate
this reduces to these Matrix elements
for hermitian Matrix this must be equal
to the original Matrix a which in terms
of Matrix elements is equal to this
comparing the diagonal terms we see that
the complex conjugate of a11 equals a11
which we can write down explicitly
and we also see that the complex
conjugate of a to 2 equals a to 2 which
again we can write down explicitly
these imply that for a hermitian matrix
the diagonal elements must be real
numbers
moving on to the off diagonal terms we
can compare this entry with this entry
which implies that a21 and a12 are
complex conjugates of each other for
hermitian Matrix
the second pair of off-diagonal terms
leads to the same conclusion
so overall we have that for a general
hermitian Matrix a The Matrix elements
are such that the diagonal entries are
real
and the off diagonal entries are complex
conjugates of each other
right so what do these results imply for
the expansion coefficients D when we
want to write the hermitian a matrix in
the basis of the identity plus parallel
matrices
let's start with d0 which remember is
equal to this expression
as a11 and a to 2 are real
that means that the expansion
coefficient d0 is also real
in a similar way we have that D3 is
equal to this expression and therefore
D3 is also real
for D1 we have this expression
and using the fact that a12 is equal to
the complex conjugate of a21 we can
rewrite it like this
and remember that the sum of a complex
number with its complex conjugate is
equal to two times its real part
this means that we end up with D1 equal
to the real part of a21
in turn this means that D1 is also a
real number
finally we have this expression for D2
again using the relation between a12 and
its complex conjugate we can rewrite it
like this
remember that the difference of a
complex number and its complex conjugate
is proportional to its imaginary part so
that we end up with this
this implies that D2 is a real number
and what does all of this mean in the
first part of this video we've shown
that we can write any complex two by two
Matrix a in terms of the identity Matrix
plus the party matrices
in this General case the expansion
coefficients D are complex numbers
what we've now shown is that if we
restrict our analysis to hermitian two
by two matrices then the expansion
coefficients D all become real numbers
as real numbers are easier to work with
than complex numbers this is an
important simplification when
considering commission operators and as
her Mission operators represent physical
observables in quantum mechanics you
will find yourself using these results
constantly
right so time to summarize we've shown
that the identity Matrix here together
with the powderly matrices here and here
and here form a basis for the space of
two by two complex matrices
to put it another way we can write any
two by two Matrix a like this and
expanded in terms of the identity Matrix
and the three parallel matrices
for General complex Matrix a these
expansion coefficients are complex
numbers and for our hermitian Matrix a
these expansion coefficients all become
real numbers
we've shown that the identity Matrix and
the three Parliament matrices form a
basis of the space of two by two
matrices you can find links in the
description discussing the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of a general two by two
Matrix and you also find several
applications of two-state quantum
systems I hope you liked the video and
don't forget to subscribe
foreign